some people in low-risk demographics do
not want to get
the hastily developed covid vaccine
because
they know that statistically speaking
the virus does not pose a great danger
to them
and the libs are very very upset about
this
but they have now come across what they
believe will be a sure-fire way
to convince all of these people to get
the vaccine
free fries when you get vaccinated um
i got vaccinated
you're saying i could get this a
delicious fries
why am i but there's also a burger
element to this
and let me let me check with bill
needhart is it too early in the day to
eat at birth
this could be breakfast okay
i want you to look at this and think
about uh don't make me watch again
no some people love hamburgers some
don't really want to respect
all ways of life but if this is
appealing to you just think of this when
you think of vaccination
oxidation
i'm getting a very good feeling
about vaccination right this moment if
if that is what i think of when i think
of vaccination i'm never getting any
vaccinations again
i regret getting the polio vaccination
if that is what i have to think of
the the argument is hey you animals
hey let us stick you with this needle
and we'll give you more
slop yeah you like slop don't you you
filthy
animals you gluttons yeah get the burger
that may that made me at least nine
point seven percent
less likely to get the vaccine i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely gross my favorite comment
yesterday from
paula christopherson who says i've
listened to knowles for a couple of
months now
and i'm radicalized i know you know
paula what you don't realize is that
comment is going to come up in court
someday when i've been
fully charged with crimes against
wokeness and i'm
on trial to figure out which gulag i'm
going to get sent to they're going to
say here's the evidence
this lady was radicalized and it's true
of course i mean if you
now if you believe that we need to trans
the kids and men can be women you are
mainstream you're normal you're a
humanitarian
and if you think like maybe we shouldn't
do that you're you're a radical
welcome to the radical side
how did this happen one great way to
figure out how this all happened is to
study history and a great way to do that
the great courses with a library of over
13
000 audio and video lectures there
really are so
many topics to explore on the great
courses plus get unlimited access to
stream thousands of courses
from top experts in their fields like
how to build a better financial plan
how to control stress and make it work
for you even how to play guitar
like a pro like me you know like you
know like me or eric clapton or prince
or whoever the great courses plus has
something for everyone
and it's all thoroughly vetted
fact-based information when you download
the app this is the key to it
when you download the app you can watch
or listen on any device you can start on
your phone
and let's say you're working out or
something you've got a course going and
you're watching on your phone you're
listening then you can switch over to
the tv later on
pick up where you left off it's just
great i because
none of us are getting an education at
school anymore truly these days where
schools are closed
it's really important to give yourself
the opportunity for that education and
you can do it just in your downtime 15
minutes here or there what are you
waiting for sign up for the great
courses plus today
right now sign up for the quarterly plan
to get an extra month for free
just go to thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles do not miss out sign up and
redeem your free month at the great
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles what the libs are trying to
create is an elaborate system of
carrots and sticks to get us to do what
they want us to do
and you've seen the carrot
the carrot is is the cheeseburger bill
de blasio
that that disgusting glutton just
letting
juice drip down his face on television
because he thinks that's going to entice
us
that's the carrot and then the stick
is joe biden who tweeted out yesterday
quote
the rule is now simple get vaccinated
or wear a mask until you do the choice
is yours
no and no i think i'm not
vaccinated i don't have any plans to get
vaccinated anytime soon and i'm not
wearing a mask i'm not wearing a mask
basically anywhere
the only place they make me wear a mask
and i have no way around it
is on airplanes because you're in that
little tin can and they'll arrest you if
you don't
otherwise i ain't doing it ain't wearing
a mask hugging people
shaking hands i'm like two seconds away
from just french kissing people on the
street
because that is how unafraid i am of
this thing
and so joe biden knows that this is sort
of an empty threat
uh he knows there's really no way to
enforce this especially because the
governors are the ones that are really
gonna be doing this and you've got
governors like ron desantis in florida
who are who are
who are pushing the nulls option on
licking doorknobs and kissing strangers
at this point you know so totally open
frankly desantis has been open now for
a year but other states are following
suit so biden knows this isn't going to
work and
the the dominant liberal regime is going
to have to loosen up on some of the
rules which is what they're doing right
now the cdc
has come out and said this is so
wonderful you're so lucky they've said
if you're vaccinated
there is no need in most circumstances
to wear a mask
indoors today cdc is updating our
guidance for fully vaccinated people
anyone who is fully vaccinated can
participate
in indoor and outdoor activities large
or small without wearing a mask or
physical distancing
if you are fully vaccinated you can
start doing the things that you had
stopped
doing because of the pandemic we have
all longed for this moment when we can
get back
to some sense of normalcy
based on the continuing downward
trajectory of cases
the scientific data on the performance
of our vaccines
and our understanding of how the virus
spreads that moment has come
for those who are fully vaccinated now
do you see what's
changed here what was it two three weeks
ago we were being told by the
public health professionals that even
once you're vaccinated
you still need to wear a mask you still
need to socially distance
nothing can change it doesn't matter
that you're vaccinated doesn't matter
that your friends are vaccinated
you can't change anything fauci was
pushing this
most prominently and then what happened
well just just like they do
it seems like every few days here they
completely changed the guidance
why because there was no scientific
discovery that that helped
that led them to this conclusion it was
a political realization
they want people to get the shot people
aren't getting the shot
the reason people aren't getting the
shot is because nothing changes if they
get the shot
fauci was telling them no you still have
to wear the mask sheep
you still have to physically distance
you sheep and so they said okay well if
i've got to do all this nonsense
regardless of whether or not i get the
shot then i'm just not going to get the
shot
so now fouchy the head of the cdc joe
biden
realized oh okay if we want if we want
to
incentivize people to get the shot we
actually have to give them something
once they do it so now what they're
saying is
you can not wear a mask and you can
hang out indoors with people okay i've
been doing that since the very beginning
i've been doing that since
at the very least last easter
if i guess even earlier than that you
know it's easter was like two weeks
after was two weeks to slow the spread
but even before that i've just been
ignoring these people
the whole time and you know what
my life's been great it's been awesome
and i
i really do wish that other people
had tuned these guys out early on
because they've squandered so much time
people cancelling weddings people
canceling social events
people not seeing their loved ones some
some of those elderly loved ones who
have died in the meantime
and they didn't do it because they were
listening to these idiots at the
egghead agencies instead of just
ignoring them so it's great now they're
saying okay michael you can ignore us
and i say okay
well you know cool i'll keep on keeping
on then fellas that sounds
that sounds great not everyone's gotten
the message from the cdc
namely joe biden who is supposed to be
the big boss here joe biden is not
following the updated cdc guidance
he is still wearing a mask indoors even
though he's been vaccinated and
everyone around him has been vaccinated
why is that well
a a biden advisor here has
come out andy slavitt and said no no the
reason that joe is going to wear a mask
when
all you people are not is because a
different set of rules
applies to very important people well
look i think people have been vaccinated
are starting to get a little bit
impatient with um what can i do
um you know can i go indoors can i take
mass off etc and i think the cdc is
getting there step by step
so right now you can do pretty much
everything outdoors without a mask
you can do everything indoors if you're
around vaccinated people without a mask
why were they all wearing masks in there
yesterday i don't think that i'm not
sure that the president is the average
uh person i i personally think there's a
lot of protections around the president
why does he need lots of secret service
agents why does he
why do they you know belt and suspender
everything with the president because
he's a very important person
and i think you shouldn't take your mark
just by what you see in the oval office
i think most people
if you're indoors around other people
that are vaccinated cd says it's okay
and i think you should listen to the cdc
on that
what the president has secret service
around him
because people are trying to kill him
with bullets and guns
and most of us do not have people coming
after us with bullets and guns and by
the way when they do we
we will either conceal carry or some
people have security right so
that makes sense the virus does not
discriminate against
very important people if the virus is a
virus right it just
infects anybody who's who's vulnerable
to it
so if the cdc is now saying if you're
vaccinated you are not at risk of the
virus
everybody you can look just like joe
biden you'll be exactly the same age you
share all of the same characteristics
then why is the virus going to be
particularly dangerous to biden
it doesn't make any sense but then
joe biden has not made any sense for a
very long time he was asked this is
almost sad if the guy weren't sort of
hobbling along
half trying to pretend to be president
and and run our lives for us i would
feel pretty bad for the guy
he was just asked about what's going on
in israel and the palestinian
territories right now
and if you can make sense of his answer
please
leave leave the translation in the
comment section because i can't
quite make heads or tales of it i had a
brief conversation with them yesterday
and i have my
my intelligence community the
defense department as well as
the state department have been in
contact with all of their counterparts
in
not only in israel but in the region and
one of the things that i have seen thus
far
is that there has not been
a significant overreaction the question
is
how
how we get to a point where they get to
a point where
there is a significant reduction
in the attacks particularly
the rocket attacks that are
indiscriminately fired
into population centers i've been
looking at the
in israel they had people
there firing there and i looked and i
talked to
oh what was that is there anything huh
what happened the guy
is clearly not up to the job and you see
it reflected in his foreign policy by
the way i i'm
under no misapprehension that joe biden
is actually running things over there
but the people that he's empowered are
just as exhausted as he is maybe not
physically
but ideologically they're just returning
to the same
exact middle eastern strategy that
failed for decades and decades and
decades to bring about any semblance of
peace
then trump comes in completely upends
that
that policy and doubles the number of
arab countries that that have recognized
israel
and gets two historic peace deals
and then what happened biden comes in
and it's the same zombie
president in the same zombie government
with the same zombie policies giving us
if it feels like uh night of the walking
dead or something like that
not good not very virile if you want to
be virile one great way to do it is grow
a beard
not everybody can you know have the
slicked back hair and the
swarthy skin and the you know kind not
everybody and the sweaters and the
blazers
but if you want the second best way to
be manly you can grow a beard and when
you grow beard you need beard supply
a lot of men want to be able to grow a
beard
grill meat and drink handcrafted booze
ideally all at the same time thanks to
the manliest giveaway ever
some lucky guy will be doing those
things for free do you know
how by winning a stash of goods
from beard supply apostrophe s-t-a-c-h-e
do you get it from beard supply meat
church desert door howler brothers and
more
terrific brands for the red-blooded
american male one lucky winner will get
a collection of beard oils and grooming
essentials tools for grilling and
leather care
and a 200 gift card for an outdoor
menswear shopping spree
up your game with the stash of goods but
don't delay
beard supplies spring giveaway is ending
soon head on over to beersupply.com
giveaway to enter that is
beardsupply.com
giveaway to enter and what will you win
well you know
you could win a stash of goods good luck
joe biden appears very confused
however there are believe it or not
people who are even more confused than
joe biden
i'm speaking of the first
transgender bishop in the
evangelical lutheran church
so the evangelical lutheran church in
america
is apparently a mainline protestant
denomination
and over the weekend it became the first
one to elect a transgender bishop
meaning that a lady pretending to be a
man
is now considered a bishop in an
organization pretending to be a church
we are underneath many many layers of
pretense at this point
she said and i actually i have to
couch this here because i say she
because she's a lady who's pretending to
not be a lady but it's not even so
simple as she's pretending to be a man
she's still going by the name megan
megan roarer
and her pronouns are
are they and him
so when she is the subject of a sentence
she pretends to be multiple people but
when she is the object of the sentence
she pretends to be a single person
who is also a man this
i i would say the nearest analog i've
heard to this
is in the bible when uh when you you
hear uh
various spirits crying out from bodies
we are legion we
you know they say that you cannot do
that you cannot be multiple people
at one moment or in one grammatical
structure and then a single person in
another grammatical structure
and you can't be a man if you're a woman
and you
and you can't be a bishop if you are a
woman or
even if you're a woman pretending to be
a man caught up confused enough okay
here's what she said
the first council of nicea's first
action was to try to limit the
leadership roles of trans pastors and
bishops
i'm going to put a pause there i'm a
little skeptical of that claim
you know the council of nicaea did a lot
of stuff but i don't okay
i'm going to put a little pause there
i'm grateful that the lutherans of the
sps
elca are beginning to dismantle this
and some of the other hurdles by poc
i don't what is the bipark does anyone
know what bipac i know it's a like a
race thing or a sex thing or something
it's bi
is it a bisexual thing or is it a bi is
it like black
because that pocket i assume is person
of color but anyway i don't know i'm
sure someone will give me the update
uh other hurdles that by poc and lgbtq
pastors misspelled encounter
uh so uh with regard to the claims about
the first council of nicea
that didn't happen because that's not a
thing that's not
it isn't i'm not just saying that
transgender bishops
i'm saying that it's not a thing oh the
the producers are updating me now by poc
means black and indigenous people of
color and i can tell i'm looking at a
picture of this woman
she is most certainly none of those
things
but i don't know it's just now it's just
slogans we did a whole show yesterday on
the slogans and you just
spout them unthinkingly uh it's not a
thing you can't
you just simply cannot be a woman
who has all the physical characteristics
of a woman but then because
she is confused in some way is on some
deeper meta physical level of man that
just
isn't true and and the irony of course
that she's making this claim about the
first council of nicaea
is that the christian understanding of
human nature is
directly contrary to
her claim about human nature the
christian understanding of human nature
is that where body and soul joined
inextricably on earth
the transgender claim about human nature
is
agnostic claims the idea that we really
were secretly something other than the
way we look
and the way that we physically are so
that did not happen at the first council
of nicaea
something that did happen at the first
council of nicaea
saint nicholas punched the jerezyark
arius in the face
because he just couldn't stand his
heresy anymore
santa claus himself got pretty rough
with the very charismatic and popular
areas because he was
spatting heresy you know not
not very open-minded man not just going
to debate everything in the free
marketplace of ideas you know and the
best ideas are going to win out no
uh this actually the whole purpose of
the council right
is not just to include everything and
everybody
but ultimately to exclude things
to exclude heretical ideas and
organizations
because that's the only way that you can
have a church it's the only way you can
define
and forget a church it's the only way
you can have any
discreet thing a nation is a nation
because the things outside of it are not
the nation an idea is an idea because
things that contradicted are not that
idea
that that is a very important purpose
here and the the libs try to
make us forget that but many
conservatives have just gone along with
it
look we're just open-minded we just
we're free speech absolutists you know
this is
this is the fundamental flaw with our
strategy the last several decades
that i take up in my upcoming book
speech list controlling words
controlling minds which is available now
for pre-order doing great on the
pre-order yesterday i also have to make
an apology for those on this show
i i plugged the book too many times
yesterday i
plugged it five times and uh but you
know after the dings and everything by
the fifth one
the screen started to shake and
ultimately cracked
so i'm sorry it was very scary for me
here in the studio as well but i'm sure
it was
very scary for the audience and i'll
i'll try i'm going to try to pull it but
i'm going to try to restrain
myself just a little bit a little bit
more today
it is not just this weird lutheran
church
that has mistaken ideas about identity
and
and its mission and the idea that things
can be totally open forever and ever and
ever
the us army has gone totally woke as
well
we played a couple of weeks ago a cia
recruitment ad about some woman talking
about i'm proud i'm brilliant
i'm a latina woman feminist
intersectional and just this woke
insanity it made me
want to just abolish the cia the first
chance i possibly can
but unfortunately now the army is
following suit
this is the story of a soldier who
operates your nation's patriot missile
defense
systems
it begins in california with a little
girl
raised by two moms although i had a
fairly typical childhood
took ballet played violin
i also marched for equality i like to
think i've been defending freedom from
an early age
i finished high school at the top of my
class and then attended uc davis
where i joined a sorority full of other
strong women
but as graduation approached i began
feeling like i'd been handed so much in
life
a sorority girl stereotype i needed my
own adventures
my own challenge and after meeting with
an army recruiter
i found it a way to prove my inner
strength
and maybe shatter some stereotypes along
the way
[Music]
i'm us army corporal emma malone lord
and i answered my calling
huh so when i was a kid i'm gonna this
is gonna date me go way back
the army recruitment ads were a bunch of
tough guys jumping out of airplanes and
shooting guns and stuff like that
and the slogan was be all that you can
be and it was like really tough guys and
now
now the army recruitment ads are about
how
lesbians on santa monica pier raised a
ballerina
who then joined the army later and
and and what is she like what's she do
what's the
what's the mission what's that doesn't
it's just the identity is the mission
you see here the sh i'm not surprised
that the
the army and the cia are doing this i
mean these are
defenders of the establishment if
anything is a defender of the
establishment surely it would be the
military
and the intelligence communities right
the national security state
and the establishment at this point has
totally gone woke it's totally delved
into identity
and there's this shift this is actually
i'm gonna totally hit the the plug
counter again today
because this is this is a shift that i
detail in my epic speechless
which is that under political
in under the old moral order what
matters most is what you
do under the new political correctness
code what matters most is what you
say all the language we use all the woke
jargon
under the old moral order we found our
identity
in god right god who says i am that i am
right that's that the essence of being
we find our identity out there so we
don't think about ourselves very much
under the new woke leftist
moral order all we ever think about is
who we
are all we ever think about is our own
identity and my priest father
george rutler famously said that when
you
lose your identity in the i am when you
when you divorce your identity
from the i am you're left with a pitiful
question which is who am i
and you see this mostly on the left i'm
black i'm a woman i'm a lesbian i'm a
bipod transgender they him bishop
lutheran whatever and but you see it in
some identitarians on the right i'm
white or i'm
nordic or i'm this or i'm that or i'm
this or i'm that
uh all of that though is such a shift
from the old idea and
you see it so clearly in the army
because the point of the art you know
what the point of the army is kill our
enemies that's the point kill
and deter by killing deter the other
ones
people who want to harm us but now that
shift of
doing is totally that sense of doing is
totally gone
all of the recruitment for the cia as
well is
who i am what i can who i am who i'm
going to be
in my identity in my mind not what i'm
actually doing but in
my mind in my mind i can
make a hell of heaven or heaven a hell
is what what satan said in paradise lost
and
we're starting to see it all around us
speaking of bad art
we you know we see this awful ridiculous
recruitment ad from the
united states army but it's not just the
united states which is producing really
bad art
london now in london mayor
sadiq khan has uh spent seven million
pounds
so what is that what i don't know the
exchange rate right now but you're
talking certainly north of 10 million
dollars 14 million dollars maybe
um on a new public art
and one of the things that he
wanted to have redesigned is the sign at
piccadilly circus one of the subway
steps
okay so if you go into this tube station
in london now you will see
some pictures made by david hockney
actually just one picture
which could have been made on microsoft
paint in 1995.
just an o it's a yellow o and then a
purple
drawing it says piccadilly circus and
the s is kind of below
the rest of it and that's on a white
background that's it
i could have made this in 90 seconds
probably and this who knows how much
money this guy got and the mayor of
london
tweets that quote brilliant work from
david hockney and piccadilly the first
of a series of major art projects we've
commissioned
as part of our brand new let's do london
campaign lots more to come very soon
hashtag david hockney and everybody
is making fun of this i i can tell you
this art is terrible and i have a little
bit of
authority on this topic because i am one
of the most successful modern artists
alive today
this is tr i am i'm this is not a joke
the blank book i've sold hundreds of
thousands of copies of a blank
book the book is just a little picture
on the front
of some blank stuff on the back and then
a bunch of blank stuff in the middle
with a bibliography that is a modern art
piece
i hate modern art but that certainly is
a modern art piece
and it's just about as popular a modern
art piece as anyone else and i can tell
you
i speak with credibility here modern art
is terrible what is so terrible about
this
well first anyone can do it
right there's no artistry there's no
skill here
any anyone could do the blank book right
anyone could do the piccadilly circus
sign
anybody can do the urine
that urinal is one of the most famous
modern rp's one of the earliest two
i mean the the examples abound
anybody can do it but but not anybody
did do it michael
you you did the blank book and no one
else did okay i guess yeah but it's
still
it's that's still a problem that it
requires no actual skill
uh second it's ugly
it's the piccadilly circus thing is not
beautiful it's lopsided it's ugly
like so much modern art it it
seems to be part of a cult of ugliness
you see this especially with modern
architecture post-modern architecture
it's
hideous it's inverted the li the angles
are all wrong it's it's incongruous
because the the thought process here is
that
all of our standards of beauty are just
totally socially constructed they're not
true there's nothing eternally true
there's no rhyme or reason to the
universe and so if i
you know if i paint the mona lisa or i
have a urinal on a wall they're both
equally beautiful right it's just
because it's just beauty's in the eye of
the beholder but it's just
it's all just so if we lived in a
society where we were
socialized and conditioned to think that
the urinal is more beautiful than the
mona lisa then we would think that
there's
nothing just intrinsic to the art that
makes us
attracted to it okay and it's childish
this piece in particular the piccadilly
circus thing is it is
designed to to look like a child made it
but there's a difference between child
like and childish
we're told that you can't get into
heaven unless you have child if you
unless you were like a child right in
the sense of childlike wonder
childlike innocence but there's a flip
side too i can say this is a
new parent you know children can be
little brats
quite a lot everyone who's ever been
around a child knows that
and this art is childish it's
it's just not up to snuff and there
really is such a thing as beauty
and there really is such a thing as
goodness and there really is such a
thing as truth
and everybody can deny it and we can
have that ugly piccadilly circus thing
up
everywhere all over the country and it
still
won't be beautiful even if a bunch of
people pretend
it still won't be because those
transcendentals beauty goodness truth
are eternally true
speaking of childish british creations
prince harry is whining about being in
the spotlight
prince harry you know for a guy who
doesn't like attention
this guy sure sure attracts a lot of
attention and seeks a lot of attention
he was whining about being in the
spotlight
on a podcast helplessness yeah that's my
biggest sort of achilles heel
yeah feeling helpless hurts it really
hurts
yeah and that's when you think yourself
shh like i got the privilege i've got
the platform
i've got the influence and even i can't
fix this yeah
i can't change this i was liking it to
truman's show
have you seen that movie between the
truman show and being in a zoo
i think the biggest issue for me was
that being born into it you inherit
the risk you inherit the risk that comes
with it you inherit every element of it
without choice
and because of the way that the uk media
are they feel an ownership over you
mm-hmm literally like a full-on
ownership and then they give the
impression to some of their well most of
their readers
that that is the case but i think it's a
really dangerous place to be
if you don't have a choice but then of
course then people quite rightly will
turn around and go so what if you didn't
have a choice it was privilege
so if prince harry really wants privacy
he just needs to stop going on shows he
just needs to sort of back away
and live his private life with a lot of
money and have his privacy but he
doesn't want that
he want he only wants glowing fawning
media coverage
and and to placate his insane wife but
he doesn't
he he's not actually seeking the thing
that he says he's seeking
he just wants everyone to be really nice
to him and no one ever to be mean to him
he wants to have all the benefits of
being in the public but none of the
downside of being in the public and that
simply is not
how it works we need real leaders right
now before we get into the mailbag i
have to give a shout out
ron desantis doing a great job as
governor of florida ron desantis
just pardoned a couple that had been
arrested for keeping their gym
open he just pardoned them he said nope
the sorry this
crazy public health state
you're not going to face consequences
for that we're gonna we're gonna
bring some justice here through the
pardon system he's also pardoning anyone
who was arrested for not masking
or social distancing one of the most
orwellian and ridiculous phrases
of my lifetime this is great stuff this
is great leadership
all the other governors should be
following suit no question about it
great stuff obviously desantis would
appear to have his eyes
on a uh on the highest political prize
in 2024 and he's doing a very good job
setting himself up for that
still need to see more from him
obviously it's early on but but he's
doing really good stuff
also speaking of real leaders they
booted liz cheney out of republican
leadership that's good
that had to happen uh the person they
wanted to replace her is this woman
elise stefanick but elise stefanik is
much more liberal than liz cheney
um at least to fanuc it was
she voted for the equality act that
crazy transgender bill
she voted for amnesty for illegal aliens
she voted
i mean she's just she posed a lot of
trump priorities but then at the very
end of the trump administration she sort
of came around to him
so president trump likes her a lot and
endorsed her for this position there is
an
actual conservative right now who is
challenging her chip roy
chip roy is a solid conservative
there's no perfect candidate people are
going to say well there's this issue
with chip roy well there's this issue
sure but some people are squishier than
others a gop that respects its
conservative base
will put chip roy in leadership and a
squish gop will elevate elise stefanik
and it's just that simple
trump likes stefanik right now you know
i love trump
you know big big supporter of the guy
and voted for him twice
elise stefanik ain't it she just ain't
it
chip roy much much more conservative
it's not even close it's not even a
question very glad there is a choice not
just an
echo and they're not just going to cram
stefanik down our throats once they
booted liz cheney out
you got to be on the lookout right now
for ben's new book the authoritarian
moment i've told you
that if i run for office that this is
going to be my campaign slogan
knowles 2024 the authoritarian moment
the authoritarian moment is right now
available for pre-order at amazon barnes
noble or any other major bookseller
it is really terrific to pre-order ben's
book
right after you pre-order speechless
controlling words controlling lines that
you can also get on all these places if
you've been wondering what it's like to
watch candace live well guess what now's
your chance to find out
tickets to join candace's live studio
audience in nashville are
free they're free yes that is a price
even i can afford they're free but only
to all access members
they're limited to her monday tapings
throughout the month of june get 20
off an all-access membership right now
by using the code all access at checkout
just head on over to dailywire.com
tickets to secure your spot uh hurry up
spots are obviously gonna go fast uh
just head on over to dailywire.com
tickets to be a part of the experience
we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the show my favorite
time of the week the mailbag
first question from scott michael my
girlfriend
and i are moving across the country for
her job and we're going to live and
start our adult lives together
we're both fresh out of college i want
to get married i know she does too
i know what your answer is going to be i
agree
kayla as long as you got that so where's
the question uh however we can't really
afford to have a wedding with our
friends and family there who will
we will soon live far away from and i
feel that the legitimacy of a courthouse
wedding is questionable
as we're not swearing our vows in front
of god and family i was hoping you might
have some thoughts and advice came for
ben stayed for an old subscribe for
clavin okay well i guess that's
guess that's fine that works well enough
for me
get married you knew the answer you
wrote into the show
to get the answer that you knew i was
going to give you just get married
you want to do it your girlfriend wants
to do it you're right you've gotten past
the hurdles
i wish i'd gotten married younger than i
did it
in the culture that i come from getting
married at
you know 28 or 27 it's like you've got a
child bride you know in
uh in in secular new york culture
people are saying no you can wait until
you're 40 wait until you're 50. but if
you come from a good culture
and you and your your girlfriend have
your priorities in line
then just get married you don't need to
do it in front of a courthouse you can
do it in a church
if let's say you don't have you don't
have 50 000 lying around to throw some
grand
elaborate fancy wedding okay do you have
like
two thousand dollars can you scrounge up
like two thousand dollars i bet you can
and for that you can have a very nice
wedding in a church so it will be very
very beautiful more beautiful than most
of the nonsense people do today
when they try to make it all up
themselves on some you know some
fancy location or in some dining hall or
something like that if you're in a
church you already got
a lot of beautiful architecture for you
you don't have to pay a penny for it
and then have the reception either in
the parish hall
or i don't know i don't know if you may
be protestant and uh you know i'm sure
there's some
church hall somewhere and uh you can
cater it very cheaply i i've been to
uh a number of weddings in the last four
or five years
and some some of them have been you know
seventy thousand dollar crazy blowouts
and some of them have been like
three thousand dollar very modest
affairs and
sometimes the more modest ones are much
more beautiful than the crazy elaborate
ones
so i would just do that do not do not
put the cart before the horse here
this is an observation that actually
speaking of staying for clavin he made
early on which is that as weddings have
gotten crazier and crazier and crazier
marriage has become more and more
shallow
so the the appearance of the thing has
gotten really elaborate
but the thing itself is atrophied what
is important what you're going to want
is to be married you can do that
i'm not saying you can do it for free
but you can do it before god
and before at least some people in your
community for not a lot of money
and by the way you're gonna have to
start making a bunch of money anyway
once you get married so you know if you
if you can
scrounge up a little bit of cash to
cater you know cater uh i don't know
cater at the local deli cater
chick-fil-a and have a night and just
have
you'll have a lovely time you'll have
wonderful memories the one thing i
wouldn't skimp on is the photographer
you actually do want to have a good
photographer
and then you'll be married and your life
is starting and you don't need to worry
about planning a party for three years
because you are now you get to play in
your life together and your family
from joshua hello mr knowles my question
is i have started a new job and they are
wanting us to be
tolerant and accept the transgender
ideology of children oh my gosh
the person teaching the class said they
were a christian but decided they would
just accept this ideology
i just don't see how they can say
they're christian but are okay with tr
transiting the children what do i do i
feel like i should speak out
but i also don't want to be ridiculed
for my beliefs thank you so much for
everything that the daily wire does i
will continue
to listen and be an all-access member
well since you're a christian you'll
remember
that the uh the they turned jesus into a
clown
do you remember that do you remember
when the roman centurions
when they put jesus in the silly costume
with the robe
and the staff and the crown of thorns
and they mocked him and beat him and
made fun of him and ridiculed him
that it is not uh a fear
that you might have that you'll
experience some ridicule for your faith
that is a promise of the faith so i
wouldn't worry about that yeah
transiting the kids is just that's not
not permitted i would speak out courage
is the prerequisite for all of the other
virtues without courage you can't have
any of the other virtues and people
write in all the time they say hey
should i have integrity or should i just
go along to get along but then someday
i'll have integrity down the line
no you won't you won't have integrity
down the line if you keep your head down
now because you'll just keep your head
down forever and then you'll die
so yeah you should certainly speak out
and you know what you might you might
lose your job
so i'm sorry that i have to be the one
to tell you that you've got to be
willing to lose your job to stand
against transiting the kids but
you do and you should get a better job
um this does not mean that you have to
be flamboyant about every single one of
your views all the time
but if it comes down to hey you need to
go along with transiting the kids
you just can't do that no no one should
be doing that from selena
hey michael i'm a junior in high school
and i go to a catholic school
i'm getting confirmed into the church
soon great and i i asked one of my
teachers to be my sponsor i really
respected her and how nice she is
she's done a lot of great things for
people in class someone had told her
that i'm a conservative
i never hide the fact that i am but i
guess my teacher didn't realize it
after class she told me to rethink my
decision on picking her as my sponsor
for confirmation because of my political
beliefs she's a raging liberal and i
never held it against her until now
because she
started making rude remarks about the
fact that i'm a conservative should i
rethink who my confirmation sponsor
should be thank you for being you i
never would have made the decision to
become catholic without listening to you
selena wow that's great thank you very
much i'm so pleased to hear that
when people tell you who they are you
should believe them
so what i would say here i don't know
obviously the specifics of your
situation
i had plenty of extremely liberal
teachers and i'm still in touch with
many of them actually
from high school and even earlier uh so
i'm
and we get along great and they'll tease
me about my politics and i'll tease them
about their politics and we would even
do it when i was in school and it really
wasn't a big deal
it was kind of fun but here as in
as in all things you can you can utter
the same
sentence and if you utter it with love
and humility it's going to have a very
different meaning
than if you utter it with resentment and
pride
so if your teacher is saying ah here
comes here's that
knuckle dragon attila the hun selena
okay hey selena how you doing you know
hey are you sure you want me to be your
confirmation sponsor
you know i'm a big lib you know i got
the co-exist bumper you sure are okay
that's if it's sort of joking and loving
that's one thing
if it is as you say rude
passive-aggressive if she was
serious when she said you should rethink
this then
of course you should under no
circumstances should you
have her be your advisor here i mean
your spiritual uh mentor coming into the
faith
your sponsor into the church also
because depending on how much of a live
she is she's
very likely uh a heretic right
to put it bluntly we started out talking
about heresy earlier on uh
if she is a huge lib if for instance she
supports legal abortion
that's a big big problem if she supports
redefining marriage if she supports
transiting the kids or something like
that i mean that
you you really should run in the
opposite direction when you're talking
about a sponsor
so i think it does depend on the
uh on the meaning of what this this
teacher is saying you know
and the sense in which her comments have
been made
but uh yeah if she's telling you who she
is then then believe her
next question from tegan hey michael i'm
from a small farming community in
northern utah i've been a listener for a
couple years
just subscribed last week i'm a big fan
of your show
why do politicians and people always
quote that quote our democracy is at
stake when our country is not a true
democracy
what is the correct term to destroy
describe our political system
i hear strong conservatives often
describe it as a constitutional republic
what are your thoughts
this is a keen insight yes there is a
distinction
between republics and democracies but
it's not so cut and dry as
as they're being totally different uh
there there's
considerable overlap in the way these
terms are used especially
in regard to our own country because
the real complicating factor here is the
the the framers describe this
distinction in the federalist papers
but the examples they give of republics
very often are
direct democracies and the the examples
they give democracies or republics and
so it's just
very confusing i would
focus less on those abstract terms
and more on the nature of the the
government itself we have a specific
constitutional structure it is different
than other republics it is different
than other democracies
it is unique it has its own unique
traditions it has its own unique
uh pillars of government and it's
evolved in different ways
it's been transformed in different ways
too
the phrase our democracy is at stake is
just silly nonsense i did a whole show
yesterday on dead
dumb rhetoric mostly from the left but
there's a fair share of it on the right
as well
and and this would be a good example of
that i mean this is one that is used
almost exclusively by libs who despise
democracy right
they're people who from the progressive
project starting a hundred years ago
took political power away from the
people and gave it to
egghead technocrats to run our lives for
us very anti-democratic in
in uh in a lot of ways so and it's this
phrase is also used by the squishy
republicans who want to suck up to the
libs because
they're just court jesters in the
kingdom of liberalism and their whole
job is to lose with dignity even though
they don't have dignity at all
so all of that to say
get into the specifics here how is our
democracy at stake
you you heard this phrase a lot with
january 6th they almost they
came into our democracy our sacred
temple of democracy
first of all in our sacred temple of
democracy very little legislation is
done
in the capital most of it's done at the
agency the executive agencies
but furthermore i think the real threat
to our democracy
the more serious threat came when blm
burned the country down for a year
previously when maxine waters told
people to attack republicans in public
get up on them get in their face you you
form a crowd remember that
uh that that's a real that's a greater
threat but when we're only talking in
these abstract
sort of slogans then a lot of that is
lost from killian dear mr knowles in
july of last year i started dating this
girl that i truly thought i was going to
marry
after four months she broke up with me
because things got to be too busy in her
personal life and starting her first
teaching job
and pursuing an athletic career well she
was busy she said with the amount of
time this would take from her it would
put too much stress on the relationship
i should also include that my job has me
on the road a lot resulting in me being
going 15 to 18 days a week oh wow okay
you're busy too
it's been six months since we broke up
and i think better every day and i can't
seem to move on
it was a great relationship and we had
the same common interests
i can honestly say i truly loved her and
still do just the timing was not in our
favor i feel waiting around for someone
is never a good idea
but i've been on some other dates and i
can't seem to connect with anyone what
do you think of this situation what
would you do
i'm going to give you what seems like
contradictory advice
but it's really not
you should pursue the girl that you want
if you want this girl you should pursue
this girl now you got to man up to do it
so you can't just be like well if it's
on
we'll be good on your schedule and and
by the way i'm gonna i've got my
personal freedom and i'm gonna be on the
road 20 days a week but
i really no you got to man up and just
be like nope you're going to spend more
time with me
and i'm going to make an effort and i'm
going to reduce the amount i'm on the
road or something
to pursue the girl also
if she if she really just doesn't want
to be with you
if she just used the timing thing as an
excuse which she may well have done i
don't know
women try to be nice sometimes when they
dump you if that is the case
then you should not debase yourself by
pursuing a girl who is in no way
interested in you
i'm not saying you can't persuade a girl
to become interested in you but you're
not going to do it by groveling and
begging and looking like a chump
okay i know those things seem like
contradictory pieces of advice
what they ultimately come down to is be
confident
you always hear this hey man how do i
pick up a girl be confident
but i'm not confident right so just be
confident well i ca how can i be
confident if i'm not
just do it you gotta to quote the
godfather talking to johnny fontaine
you're gonna act like a man what's the
matter with you that's what you you've
got to do
and this means that sometimes you pursue
the girl quite directly
and sometimes this means a tactical
retreat okay
that the way you win a war is is not
just by rushing into battle when you're
going to lose
and it's not just by retreating wars are
not won by evacuations to quote winston
churchill but you need to
using prudence which is a very important
conservative virtue strike that balance
and above all be confident because
courage is the prerequisite of all the
other virtues one more question from
roland
michael first gotta say i love the show
your use of classical conditioning is
impressive using a bell sound to control
people's minds like the name of your
book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds i noticed today when i heard the
bell
when i heard a bell like on your show i
thought of your book well
played sir well played pretty sure i
said that name while i was reading the
question did i
oh there it is there it is everybody
have a good weekend i'll see you on
monday i'm michael moses the michael
knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin